اعمل اعمل لا تتوقف
[موسيقى]
ومن يريد ذلك في ظروف الفرنسيين هذه
غليانهم الاجتماعي ذو المسحه السياسيه
حركه مشروع لاصلاح نظام التقاعد صحيح ان
سن التقاعد في فرنسا هو من بين الادنى بين
سائر الدول الاوروبيه لكن التعديل الجديد
بدل الفرنسيين في عمومهم ظالما خصوصا
للنساء والعاملين في الوظائف الشاقه اذ
يرفع تدريجيا سن التقاعد القانوني من 62
عاما الى 64
لم ترى النقابات العماليه بدا من التصعيد
بعد اربعه ايام من مظاهرات مماثله قدرت
عدد المشاركين فيها باكثر من ثلاثه ملايين
عامل هذه المره لم تدعو الى شن اضراب عام
بالموازاه مع المظاهرات الاحتجاجيه غير ان
قطاعات كالملاحه الجويه والنقل بالقطارات
وكذلك الطاقه تشهد اضطرابات بعد تمديد
الاضراب فيها كما ان الاضرابات الواسعه
حاله دون جمع الاف الاطنان من النفايات في
مدن فرنسيه عده
الازمه المتصاعده على الجبهتين السياسيه
والاجتماعيه لا يبدو انها اربكت خطط
الحكومه فهي طرف التعديل مصدرا لتمويل
نظام الضمان الاجتماعي احدى ركائز
الانموذج الاجتماعي الفرنسي لا يبدو ان
الرئيس
والاخر قد عدل موقفه على وقع الاحتجاجات
الطاغيه على ولايته الثانيه
[موسيقى]
زاد هؤلاء استياء لجوء الحكومه الى ماده
دستوريه تقضي بالتصويت جمله واحده على
مشروع القانون بعد معركه اجرائيه حاده مع
اليسار اقر مجلس الشيوخ الفرنسي الذي
يهيمن عليه اليمين ماده رئيسيه في مشروع
تعديل نظام التقاعد
وتسرع الاغلبيه في المجلس الخطى لاقرار
الاصلاح كاملا قبل انقضاء المهله النهائيه
منتصف ليله الاحد
اذا لم طارئ ما خطه الحكومه فهي تتوقع
اقرار البرلمان بمجلسيه التعديل بحلول
منتصف الشهر الحالي لكن عليها قبل ذلك كله
اجتياز نهايه اسبوع بدت للفرنسيين حاسمه